yeah I'm only to the part where he got
branded and they're like yeah I love
that [__] they're so sick they're like a
gang you gotta get there's a price you
got to pay to work at this right yeah
you gotta get branded on your ass I just
love how The Branding he's just like ah
you would stop it yeah stop it it's
actually not that bad you've been
branded no I haven't been branded but I
[__] put a cigarette out of my hand
one time but I feel like hot steel with
I feel like sober that would make you
pass out I feel it's only like a second
though like something like press it in
there a couple seconds I mean
yeah you know yeah a couple seconds
isn't it I don't know it's over it's
over you know I I have to say your
mindset is [__] Ironclad because you
have the confidence to be like I'll take
a brain for two seconds that's what the
dude says before he gets the breeze like
[__] it I love it
so there you go Cass chat as the guy who
gets branded yeah the next guy yeah
there's a price you got to pay and work
here